ayu amirta is preparing the pre-dawn
meal for her family
as muslims in indonesia observed the
first day of ramadan
the mother of two contracted covet 19
earlier this year
but hospitals in jakarta were full and
she ended up self-isolating in a hotel
for two weeks
until she recovered
i was very worried but i spoke to my
children and my extended family every
day
and they encouraged me to fight on so
despite the pain
i was in i continued to be positive and
hope for the best
i'm very grateful that i'm healthy and
able to observe ramadan with my family
indonesia has the highest number of
covet 19 cases in southeast asia
but the country is conducting a major
vaccination drive
and has begun easing some restrictions
including allowing special prayers in
some
mosques subject to physical distancing
requirements
in neighboring malaysia some
restrictions have also been lifted
last year's ramadan was a much quieter
occasion the government had cancelled
bazaars because of the pandemic
and vendors went online this year the
markets are back
in most states but with strict protocols
everyone has to provide details for
contact tracing their temperature checks
face masks are a must after missing out
on one of the busiest months
last year vendors are hoping for a
better ramadan this time
thank god this year i can open my stall
there will always be time for my family
i open my stall from 2 to 7 p.m but at
night we have time to eat
break fast and pray together the bazaars
are popular with muslims and non-muslims
mixed feelings to be honest on one heart
side i feel quite happy because you know
it's a chance to actually support local
businesses
and eat all the yummy food but on the
other hand i'm also a bit nervous
because you know we're not out of the
woods yet we are
i really love the malay desserts but
they're a lot of work
to make so i'm glad the stalls are open
this year
the government has warned that the
bazaars may be shut down if operating
guidelines are not complied with
a reminder that even as families gather
to mark ramadan
the pandemic is not yet over florence
louis
al jazeera kuala lumpur